well I say this every week but I'm gonna
say it again I think you don't know why
you're happy tonight because well I cuz
you love me that's me where I was gonna
go with that but also Senate Democrats
delivered President Obama major victory
by blocking the Republican efforts to
screw up his Iran deal which is a
no-brainer and it's gonna go through or
maybe you're just glad to get out of the
heat I don't know maybe that's why but
no you know the Republicans never let
anything go even when they lose as they
did so they had a big rally the other
day on the Capitol against the Iran deal
and the lineup of speakers very
impressive
here's spear soup smoke Donald Trump Ted
Cruz Sarah Palin Glenn Beck Michelle
Bachman Louie Gohmert and the duck
dynasty guy this was a virtual Woodstock
of the mentally impaired it was
and Donald Trump said if you elect me we
will have so much winning you're gonna
get bored with winning you know Charlie
Sheen used to talk like this but he was
on crack I mean there was an excuse Oh
Donald from
Donald Trump I hate love talking about
Donald truck every week so this week he
picked a fight with Carly fiorina's face
have you seen it
I mean we've had Carly gone I don't
agree with her on a lot but I have
nothing against her she's a nice face
Donald Trump said look at that face
would anyone vote for that faith two
questions one has Donald Trump crossed
the line finally and two has he seen
Scott Walker because if you're gonna
pick on the face this guy looks like he
died in a fireworks accident
and then Donald Trump says I didn't mean
it about the face I'm just an
entertainer that's what he said don't
blame him he's just Trump the insult
comic dog today called Obama hockey puck
but no one remembers Don Rickles okay uh
no just an entertainer we'll you know
what Don I agree and my question is when
is the show over
there has to be some line that he can
cross write something that will turn
people up and yet every week he seems to
dare us this week I swear to God he said
something so creepy about his own
daughter he said quote what a beauty
that one
if I weren't happily married and you
know her father what does this man have
to say to be disqualified john mccain
[ __ ] megyn kelly on the rag my daughter
i wish i could have sex with her what
there are schizophrenic swith tourists
who have more control of what comes out
of them now
but when he said that thing about his
daughter his poles in the rural South
went through the roof
they were like finally someone who gets
me but forget Trump today right now as
we speak is the 14th anniversary can you
believe 14 years have passed since 9/11
teachers in Florida have boyfriends who
weren't even alive then
and you know everyone remembers and
commemorates in their own way miley
cyrus today was wearing the black
pasties mister
president mrs. Obama had a moment of
silence at the White House George Bush
wore the pants that he peed in that day
so everybody has their own and last
night listen to this on the eve of 9/11
a rainbow did you see this appeared
emanating from Ground Zero which sent an
unmistakable message to the nation
Jesus is gay
Oh down in Kentucky Kim Davis just what
no he didn't know he no yes this was the
week of Kim Davis you know this name now
we're Republicans have a new hero
Kentucky County Clerk Kim Davis the Rosa
Parks of homophobia the woman who went
to jail for five whole days rather than
issue marriage licenses to gay people
she was released on Tuesday greeted with
a huge rally led by Mike Huckabee the
White House Sharpton and they all got up
there and said God's law supersedes the
courts which actually is a very strong
legal argument in Saudi Arabia but not
here at America what country are we
living
I don't want to say that these super
religious types are always hypocrites
but here she is standing up for
traditional marriage and then we find
out she's had multiple affairs conceived
twins out of wedlock and has been
married four times that's why she can't
give marriage licenses to gay she's used
them all for herself
you